well ladies and gentlemen
hello to our traditional
report of the college meeting
this week where this month earlier
with the high representative and vice
president of the commission
mr morel mr bourrel for your
information you are also broadcast to
see it axel only at  brussels and
elsewhere but brussels you have to ask
the questions and possibly if there is
where the other journalist who wants
to ask you a question
so I give you the floor for the
debriefing thank you thank you everyone
today the commission we
held the first debate
on the guidelines on defense is in fact
a very, very important moment to hold this
debate because recent
international developments show
that in the current geopolitical contexts
the European union must
assume greater responsibility
for its  security it reinforce its role
as political material
obviously it is not enough to say it it
must have means, capabilities
and instruments in the various
political and operational fields
obviously defense remains a matter
of national competence the essential part of
European cooperation in the field of
defense takes place in the member states,
i.e. belongs to the domain
intergovernmental and without the agreement
of the member states it is difficult to make
progress in this area but at the same
time the commission has brought in a lot by
supporting industrial cooperation.
especially the fight against
hybrid threats
obviously as a representative
for foreign security
and defense policy
I have an important role in guaranteeing
consistency between the instruments of the
commission and the policies
intervening mental consistency and an
important matter in this  subject and
all efforts should be directed towards
two policy goals.  common defense issues
in these areas suddenly
underlined the importance of the
European Defense Fund which should
offer essential incentives to
encourage Member States to
work on common projects on
the basis of a strategic approach in
the development  capabilities that
meet the operational needs of
the European armies
on the one hand, therefore,
permanent structured cooperation since in English
the European defense funds and the
work of the European defense agency
finally a triangle whose consistency must be
ensured
at the same time we discussed with the
College of Commissioners
the work as of us that we call the
strategic compass iris deal with
strategic English that we pass a
French the compass and strategic
labroue the strategy that has entered a
political document  and strategic
member states have asked for repairs
to best define
defense security objectives i  identify the
threats is given and new impetus to our
initiatives
it will have the whole year to
work on it and the
commission's contribution must be invaluable the debate
was we think it is of
course one of the subjects of the bases  from the
robben commission to the current commission which will
continue the work of the previous
commission but also from the nature of
the european union in the future after
this debate we entered into a
debrief by commissioner kelly a who
says about  of the
coronavirus problems and the measures that the
commission is applying in these subjects we have
known two latest news we have
known what are the preparations that the
commission and the Croatian presidency
are developing and the last
16 min from european center for the
prevention from the spread of diseases
we are in contact with the
Chinese authorities had the ambassador and not
follow the situation closely without wanting to
raise unfounded alarms it is
obvious  that this is a subject of concern
to all European citizens and on which the
commission responsible draws resources and its
capacity for action